Yeah.
The,
the ultimate legal case,
public legal case,
uh,
or one of the ultimate ones is Julian Assange.
Oh yeah.
That's a weird,
he hasn't seen sunlight and months.
Yeah.
No Internet access.
They shut down the Internet.
Yeah.
And they're trying to kick him out now,
Ecuador.
But where's it going to go if he goes,
he's going to,
if they want him,
what?
Sweden,
they want him,
they want him in Britain.
And I don't think they've been charges filed against him here yet,
technically,
but I'm sure they want his head on a platter of what they want him for.
So preposterous.
It's so nice.
It's like a water,
right?
It's just like Al Capone.
Yeah.
Activation instead of being a mobster,
right.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's interesting because I would think that someone like Trump who is such a
conspiracy minded person would actually like Juliana massage because I'm sure
there's been,
I mean,
I don't know what he's ever said in the past.
I think it was anti,
he was anti wiki leaks from the start.
No,
but he said things about Giulia signs that were anti it.
My understanding.
Yeah.
Because there was something,
Julian Assange tweeted,
my friend,
Cassandra at fair bank,
she's a big support of him and she's like,
well,
there goes to the idea of clemency or a pardon.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So that Trump tweeted,
or Julian,
I think.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
It's a piece of praise or virtual prisoner.
Yeah.
It's like,
where's that end?
It's not gonna end.
Well,
he can get visitors though.
No,
I don't it Camela Anderson.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
But they may have taken that away.
Take that away.
I wonder how long they could stay there.
It's been years,
years.
It's been years.
Years,
yeah.
Yeah.
To be in one building.
And he,
he doesn't go outside anymore.
He can't,
they won't let them.
I don't think they,
I don't think he ever could went on the balcony.
Okay.
Now I know he doesn't see off sunlight.
That I'm positive.
That's terrible.
They give them vitamin D at least.
No.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I mean,
he's awfully pale to begin with,
but if you don't get vitamin D like you can get really sick,
but that's what they do in North Korea.
They get their skin starts falling off there.
It's been there since June 19th of 2012 there the embassy doc,
that's six years.
Whoa,
whoa.
This Christ,
how much?
Almost six and a half years.
June.
How much solitaire can you play and you don't even have internet anymore.
He has an Internet for how many months?
I'm looking at timeline is,
I want to say it's been about four or five months.
It's been a while.
I think it was more than that long.
March 27th they were suspended for the songs time.
Eight months for the Second Todd's October,
2016 fuck who the hells over at Wiki leaks still running shit.
That's the intern who's hanging in there,
you know God.
That's crazy.
Like how does that one play out?
I mean they're,
they're,
they're really what they're doing for sure.
When we're talking about punishment being a deterrent in certain situations,
that is absolutely a deterrent.
Oh,
they're making an example of him for the whistle blower.
Oh yeah.
Where's Chelsea Manning's out now?
She just had her surgery.
What surgery though?
Per transgender.
She goes,
yeah,
that one there.
She tweeted out.
I have,
I have a vagina.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Well,
there you go.
Yeah,
she's out.
She's out.
Hobnobbing and maybe using that thing.
I met her,
she came to an event.
She was very nice,
I'm sure.
But she's out.
She's out.
She's been out for a,
Obama pardoned her computer.
Her sentence,
he's locked away forever in the embassy.
And then there's Snowden,
who's also hiding right in Russia.
Right.
What?
And actually a lot of these,
yeah,
there's just Holla.
Mm MM.
After almost a decade of fighting through prison.
The courts,
a hunger strike and through the insurance company.
I finally got surgery this week.
Not lasik apparently.
Oh,
you son of a bitch.
She's wearing glasses folks.
Um,
yeah,
house.
He's going to be in Russia,
probably forever eight.
Had a lot of these farmers from South Africa.
That's where they're going to Russia and Putin is letting them in.
Really?
Yeah.
So they better learn how to write those ares backward pretty quick.
Oh,
right.
They've got weird ours.
Yeah.
Well you have to learn the whole,
the whole language and just that weird.
Ours you,
Russia,
Russians got a lot of weird ones.
We do.
We got,
oh yeah.
I was barely literate in Russia.
The letters look fake.
All letters are fake,
but they look like alien language.
You know?
It was like somebody writing something that was this once a piece of metal from
a spaceship
like Snowden is,
he's fucked too,
right.
I mean,
he can't even be public in Russia.
Yeah.
I am not sure about him.
I know,
I know.
Sorry.
I haven't been following stolen.
He's deep under.
Lindsey must know where he is though.
I mean,
there's no way the intelligence community is,
doesn't have a fucking full line on exactly where that guy is at all times.
The question,
do they know all this stuff or are they incompetent?
And there's examples of both directions.
Yeah,
I got to think they know,
or Snowden is,
I can't,
I can't.
I mean,
hi,
Glenn Greenwald talks to him all the time.
Glenn Greenwald's in Brazil.
Yeah.
That was how to glean broad,
kind of made his name,
I think,
who's also a great lefty.
Yeah,
he gets it a lot.
Yeah.
Um,
that's just,
how does that guy go on?
Like is he just in hiding,
getting his restaurants,
you know,
like sneaking in?
Like where does he,
how does he get around?
Yeah.
I don't know.
And who wants to getting some money from,
he's got to pay for food.
Right?
What does he do for food?
Yeah,
a lot of Borscht.
Fuck,
I just looked him up at Google is like kind of broken.
Here's an example of it.
It says,
when did he die?
And then it just highlights that date and it doesn't say he's not dead.
So Snowden flew to Hong Kong where he was staying there,
but that was part of his whole trip.
He had to go through it.
He,
this whole journey through a bunch of countries.
Yeah.
It's weird.
I think they tacked on Thailand or something at some point.
It is weird.
It's like,
does that guy just,
that's him forever.
That's,
that's what he does.
Who Snowden.
Yeah.
I mean,
he just tends to hide.
I think so.
Or maybe he safe in Russia and Putin is having him there as a fuck you to us.
Yeah.
I mean it must have something to do with it.
The Putin's deciding to do this,
putting wouldn't do it unless there's some advantage to him.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's a strange,
you know,
strange as these things are just these floating like a den,
uh,
like little chapters.
So these stories that are just,
you know,
we all know about them but they don't get resolved well,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They're just floating on,
hang on here and it's just thinking,
I mean,
this is why I talk about North Korea at the time since I've been there.
Everyone's still there.
Everyone I met and like thinking about six years a song has been in that one
building,
six fucking it's itself and all the people in jail also who had been jailed for
six years.
Just,
we can't wrap our heads around that six fucking year.
Thinking about where you were six years ago.
I'm thinking of where I was six years,
not just at like six years and things are deteriorating.
Right.
They want them out of the embassy.
He's got nowhere to go.
If he leaves,
he gets arrested.
He doesn't have any internet.
Yeah.
Can't see sunlight knowing that the most powerful people in the world were doing
everything they can to fucking put you in jail for life.
And you kind of already are in a sense.
I can't see it.
Julia sound,
just never in the rest of his life.
Probably going to be able to like take a jog around a park like ever.
No,
never.
We're like walk a dog.
Yeah,
it's over.
It's,
it's scary.
And the thing is a lot of this shit that he,
almost all the shit that he put out his true.
Yeah.
That's what's crazy.
It's like he's doing what journalists should be doing instead of getting up in
the press core and just pitching a fit.
Yeah.
But it is,
there's real repercussions for doing what he did and that's what they're letting
us know.
Yeah.
And they're letting us,
he said turning matter what the law is like.
What are you getting them for?
Secret sex or a surprise.
Yeah.
What?
All right.
Snowed is running.
His Twitter account says he's the president of something called freedom of
press,
which is a website and Twitter account also have the same name and they tweeted
this out a couple of days ago.
She story I'd never heard of.
It says in the latest case in the Trump administration's cracked down on leaks.
Natalie Edwards,
US Treasury employee was arrested and charged with giving suspicious bank
records involving Trump campaign associates.
Paul Manafort and Rick Gates to a news outlet in the legal complaint,
the Justice Department sided word for word conversations he allegedly had with a
reporter over and encrypted messaging APP.
The government claimed it got ahold of her phone and with it her encrypted
messages with a reporter.
Now she faces prison time.
Wow,
dude,
I'll report.
It should be using apps that this,
this make all their messages disappear.
Yeah,
like signaling.
What's that?
Yeah,
that's what he's this website.
but even then someone can take screenshots.
No,
I think something that you can't,
it's disabled automatically.
Really?
Yeah.
But you could take a picture of your phone with another phone,
obviously,
but signal.
Yeah.
My friend,
who's the knows more than anything.
I know that in resecure it,
he was signaling,
signaling,
secure drop.
And so what is signal?
What do you do with signal?
Basically it's,
it's encrypted.
So if you send messages to me,
like they v four you could set it to vanish at the certain time,
and I can't do a screenshot.
Ah,
interesting.
Yeah.
Hmm.
And it's,
it's,
it's not hackable,
apparently.
It's the best one.